Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man mit Tempest auch was Sinnvolles machen kann. Naja, eine bleibt noch im Chaos Radio, wo es heute um Tempest geht und damit bezeichnet man elektromagnetische Abstrahlung beziehungsweise das Abhören derselben. So, jetzt haben wir noch eine Stunde, es ist quasi Halbzeit. Hier rufen wir heute nicht so viele Leute an, wahrscheinlich weil sie alle wie gebannt vor dem Monitor sitzen und sich fragen, wer gerade alles zuguckt und ausliest, was sie da so für Schweinkram treiben. Wir könnten jetzt Musik spielen. Oder nicht, was meint ihr?
Ich bin für Musik.
Ganz basisdemokratisch machen wir das jetzt?
Ich enthalte mich.
Du gehst ja auch nicht wählen.
Das habe ich nicht behauptet, ich habe bloß gesagt, das ist eigentlich gar kein Sinn.
Darüber machen wir jetzt den Mantel des Schweigens und hören ein paar Stimmen. Das war jetzt aber METZ mit Voices, auch Musik, die man einfach so aus dem Netz ziehen kann, weil sie in der Creative Commons Lizenz steht. Und mir ist zu Ohren gekommen, dass es einige Leute gibt, die nicht einverstanden sind mit der Musik, die hier gespielt wird und dass andere Leute nicht so genau verstehen, worum es hier geht. Und ich kann euch nur sagen, wenn ihr ein Problem habt und was genauer wissen wollt, dann gilt ganz einfach Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 Wenn Andreas und Starbuck vom Chaos Computer Club, die hier sind und heute darüber sprechen, wie man durch die elektromagnetische Abstrahlung von Geräten Dinge herausfinden kann, sind bereit, euch jede Frage zu beantworten, die ihr dazu habt. Und zwar noch bis Mitternacht. Auch der Thomas hat angerufen. Hi Thomas!
Hallo! Ich hab neulich ein relativ komisches Phänomen gehabt. Ich hab mir ein neues Mainboard für meinen Computer gekauft und hab meine Teile wieder schön zusammengesteckt und konnte daraufhin an meiner Soundkarte hören, wie stark mein Prozessor Unterlast war. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das vielleicht was mit Tempest zu tun hatte, dass irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, irgendwelche Schaltkreise da drin genau die elektromagnetischen Wellen ausgesendet haben, die irgendwelche Schaltkreise in meiner Soundkarte dazu gebracht haben, einen Ton auszuwenden.
Das ist durchaus wahrscheinlich, ja. Also die Frage ist, ob halt irgendwie dein Prozessor das gemacht hat oder vielleicht ein Lüfter. Aber auf jeden Fall irgendwas hat das schon gesendet und hat irgendwie auch in die Soundkarte eingekoppelt. Also bei Notebooks hat man zum Beispiel relativ oft, dass der WLAN-Funkchip halt irgendwie in die Soundkarte eingekoppelt bzw. der Display-Controller. Und wenn man zum Beispiel eine schnelle Wechsel von hell auf dunkel auf dem Display umschaltet, hat man so ein Fiepen bzw. ein Knacken hört. Also das ist durchaus nicht ungewöhnlich.
Es muss aber nicht unbedingt Tempest sein, sondern es kann sich sozusagen um den generischen Fall der Side-Channels handeln. Also was bei Soundkarten, Seitenkanäle, wir hatten es vorhin davon, dass ja auch Geräusche mittlerweile möglicherweise Dinge verraten oder der Stromverbrauch und das ist so eine Stromverbrauchsgeschichte, weil so eine CPU, je nachdem, was sie rechnet, da sind da so Nullen und Einsen und die werden in Kondensatoren gespeichert und die müssen und damit der Rechner rechnen kann, mal mit Strom befüllt werden und mal wieder von Strom entleert werden und je nach dem verbrauchen die gerade mehr oder weniger Strom und das führt natürlich dazu, dass der Spannungslevel der Stromversorgung sich ändert, je nachdem, ob die CPU gerade viel oder wenig Strom braucht. Das ändert sich abhängig davon, welche Daten verarbeitet werden.
Das wäre relativ wahrscheinlich, denn man konnte eben, also an der Tonhöhe dieses Gromens, konnte man feststellen, wie stark der Prozessor unter Last war. Also wenn er unter Last war, dann war das eine sehr tiefe Suche. Und das wurde richtig, naja, nicht fliegend, aber doch schon deutlich höher von der Tonhöhe, wenn man den auf 50, das ist ein Dualcore, oder auf 100% Last gebracht hat.
Das kann gut sein. Und das hört man natürlich auf der Soundkarte, wenn die mal mehr oder mal weniger Strom auf den Verstärker tut, dann ist es halt kurz lauter oder leiser, dieses Nullsignal, was da kommt. Interessanterweise, es gibt eine Veröffentlichung, da wurde der kryptographische Schlüssel einer RSA- Operation aus einem Rechner rausextrahiert. Und zwar eine ganz ähnliche Geschichte, da ging es auch um die Stromversorgung. Allerdings, also die Spannung in so einem Computer wird ja von einem Spannungsregler konstant gehalten. Und diese Spannungsregler haben manchmal die Eigenschaft, dass sie Geräusche machen. Also wenn man viele Lüfter in seinem Rechner hat, hört man das nicht. Bei Notebooks hört man es manchmal. Wenn man eine Wasserkühlung hat, die sehr leise ist, hört man das auch.
Ist es so ein leichtes Fiepen?
So ein leichtes Fiepen.
Das macht mich wahnsinnig.
Ich habe extra die 100 Euro mehr ausgegeben für ein Mainboard, wo die Spannungsregler nicht fiepen. Und die haben echt ein Mikrofon in den Rechner reingehalten und waren in der Lage, daraus den Schlüssel, also den privaten, geheimen, kryptographischen Schlüssel zu extrahieren.
Das ist ja schon einer von den Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, die noch relativ gut dabei sind, oder? Ja, ja.
Das ist einer von den guten. Das sind diese asymmetrischen, die bei PGP verwendet werden oder wenn du per SSL auf eine Webseite gehst. Das ist schon so eine ganz schöne Standardgeschichte.
Mit einem Mikrofon.
Dann hätte ich noch eine Idee, wo man Tempest einsetzen kann für, ich sag mal, kriminelle Zwecke. Also es gibt ja noch Leute, die haben einen analogen Telefonanschluss. Und in den Fällen läuft ja das Signal auch noch analog vom Telefon, irgendwie, ich glaube 60 Hertz, glaube ich, bis zum Vermittlungskasten, der irgendwo im Dorf oder in der Stadt am Straßenrand rumsteht. Na und wenn man dort jetzt die Abstrahlung dieses Kabels oder dieses Anschlusses abhören könnte, kann man dann abhören, was der da am Telefon bremelt?
Man hat Übersprechen zwischen Telefonladung, das ist richtig. Also jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen weiter auswählen. Diese Kästen, die da rumstehen, das sind in aller Regel nicht die Vermittlungsstellen, sondern das sind die VDSL-Knoten, die sie jetzt überall hingestellt haben.
Analog, meint er.
Analog geht aber bis in die Vermittlungsstellen, das sind nicht die Kästen, die auf der Straße stehen.
So, das ist... Nee, früher hatten sie die Analog-Leitung halt direkt bis, also auf der Straße auch noch analog. Also konnte es sich halt mit dem Telefon oben raufstecken und hast halt irgendwie die Analog-Signale da rausgedrückt.
Ja, dass es raufklemmen geht, aber was man auch hat, ist übersprechen. Das heißt, wenn man so eine Telefonleitung hat, die man gerade nicht benutzt und die zufällig denselben Kabelweg verwendet, kann man möglicherweise mit viel Verstärkung noch hören, was da gesprochen wird. Also müsste gehen, ich hab's nie ausprobiert.
Also ansonsten, immer wenn es über Kabelinformationen rübergeht, um das Kabel rum halt die Antenne legen und dann braucht man halt nicht mehr wirklich viel Verstärkung, weil man halt schon ziemlich nah an den fließenden Bits dran ist. Elektronen.
Das ist schon sportlich. Dann wünsche ich euch noch viel Spaß und Chaos Radio.
Ich hatte zwei Fragen im Chat gerade gehabt. Die erste war die Qualität des Bildes bei diesem Röhrenmonitor mit einem Fernseher Heck. Also ich kenne halt auch nur irgendwie Fernsehberichte, wo sie es mal gezeigt haben, aber die Qualität war halt schon relativ gut. Also man konnte halt normale Schriftgröße konnte man halt auf dem Fernseher schon darstellen und lesen. Also beziehungsweise es war ein bisschen größere Schrift. Aber ich glaube, das Problem lag halt eher daran, dass der Fernseher selber halt nur eine definierte Auflösung hat. Das heißt, wenn man da mit einem höher aufgelösten Fernseher auf der anderen Seite abgehört hätte, hätte man wahrscheinlich auch die kleine Schrift gelesen können. Und die zweite Frage war zum Thema Abhören von Festplatten. Da muss ich ein bisschen weiter ausholen, oder?
Okay, ich hole mal ein bisschen weiter aus. So, jetzt wird es spannend für die Leute, die sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit Technik auskennen. Wir hatten es ja vorhin von der Leitung in dem dunklen schwarzen Raum, wo der Strom durchfließt. Jetzt wissen wir ja, wir haben es mit Computern zu tun. Da gibt es Nullen und Einsen, also Rechtecksignale. Das heißt, dass jedes Mal, wenn die Leitung ihren Zustand von 0 auf 1 ändert, oder wenn sie ihn von 1 auf 0 ändert, sich der Strom ändert, der durch die Leitung durchfließt und dann an dieser Stelle entsteht so eine elektromagnetische Welle, die man messen kann. Ja, jetzt ist so eine Leitung ja nicht perfekt. Das heißt, auch das Rechtecksignal, was da drauf liegt, ist nicht perfekt, sondern man kann sich vorstellen, es handelt sich dabei um einen Tiefpass. Das heißt, wenn man da mit dem OSC drauf guckt auf diesen Rechteckimpuls, dann wackelt der so ein bisschen rum, dann geht es schräg runter, dann wackelt es wieder ein bisschen. Und dementsprechend sieht das Signal aus, dass da abgestrahlt wird. Und je nachdem, wie lang jetzt diese Leitung ist und wie weit die von Masse weg ist, also abhängig von ihrer Induktivität und ihrer Kapazität, ergeben sich andere Filte-Eigenschaften des physikalischen Systems, das ich da anrege. Und dementsprechend gibt es auch Unterschiede. Das heißt, was man ja bei Festplatten hat, was man genauso bei den LC-Displays hat, was man auf Bus-Signalen hat und so weiter und so fort, ist ja, dass diese Bits alle gleichzeitig schalten. Und irgendwie in erster Näherung sieht man halt, wie viele Bits umgekippt sind. Das ist das, was wir bei den Wahlcomputern machen. Aber die sind ja alle ein kleines bisschen anders, diese Leitungen. Verhalten sich alle ein kleines bisschen anders. Und ich habe die Theorie, ich habe dazu keine Anhaltspunkte, ob es schon mal jemand getan hat, dass man die Leitungen voneinander unterscheiden können müsste. Dass man also, wenn man genau genug hinhört, die sind sozusagen alles ein bisschen anders gestimmt. Und wenn man genau genug hinhört, kann man die Töne auseinanderhalten. So kann man sich das glaube ich vorstellen. Und wenn man das kann, dann kann man wahrscheinlich auch Festplatten abhören.
Okay, aber das ist schon noch Zukunftsmusik.
Für mich jedenfalls. Das Problem ist, darüber ist so gut wie gar nichts publiziert. Also was es publiziert gibt, sind diese ganzen Analogmonitor-Geschichten. Zu Tempest von Digital-Signalen habe ich genau eine Veröffentlichung gefunden. Die kam von den Chinesen aus dem Jahre 2006 auf einer Robotikkonferenz. Also völlig themenfremd. Keine Ahnung, wie das da hingekommen ist. Die sich so mit den theoretischen Grundlagen beschäftigt hat. Ansonsten gibt es nicht viel. Der Rest ist eine Spekulation und darüber nachdenken, wie es funktionieren könnte.
Also wenn da draußen jetzt jemand sitzt, der weiß, wie man Festplatten Tempest abhört, bitte anrufen. 0331 70 97 110. Und was ich an dieser Stelle zusagen möchte, wenn ihr anruft, müsst ihr nicht Thomas heißen. Wir haben nämlich irgendwie jetzt gerade Thomas in der Leitung gehabt. Wir haben jetzt noch zweimal Thomas in der Leitung. Ihr dürft auch anrufen, wenn ihr Manfred heißt. Nein, alle Namen sind zugelassen. Einfach anrufen. 0331 70 97 110.
Dann nimm nochmal Thomas rein.
Ich nehm jetzt Thomas rein.
Hallo, ob die andere jetzt auch eine Logik sagt hat.
Hallo, du mit den Cut-Kabeln.
Ja genau.
Du bist das.
Ja, ich wollte mal fragen, wie das ist. Also diese Cut-Kabel.
Halt, was sind Cut-Kabel?
Na, das sind diese ganz normalen Internetverbindungs-Kabel oder LAN-Kabel oder Netzwerkabeln. Und ich wollte mal fragen, wie es da mit der Abhörsicherheit aussieht. Ich weiß, da gibt es ja welche, die hier geschirmt sind und wieder welche, die nicht geschirmt sind. Und diese Geschirrmten, reicht das aus oder kann man da immer noch Sachen abhören?
Also die strahlen in der Tat nicht besonders viel ab, weil die also die Menge Energie, die durch Abstrahlung in den Raum abgegeben wird, ist ja sozusagen auch die, die verloren geht und nicht am anderen Ende ankommt. Wenn man so auf der einen Seite Energie reinsteckt, ist wie so ein Wasserschlauch mit Löchern drin, kommt irgendwie, was nicht an der Seite rausgeht, kommt am Ende an. Und deswegen werden die natürlich so gebaut, dass möglichst viel am Ende ankommt. Also erstens sind das so genannte Twisted Pair-Kabel, das heißt, das sind immer pärchenweise Adern miteinander verdrillt, wo der Strom in der einen Richtung hinläuft und in der anderen Richtung zurückläuft. Dadurch heben sich die magnetischen Felder gegenseitig auf. Und wenn man also eine absolut ideal verdrillte Leitung hat, dann ist theoretisch das Feld, das da abgestrahlt wird, null. In der Praxis siehst du also nur die Abstrahlung durch die Toleranzen beim verdrillen. Und dann ist da ja bei modernen Kabeln, über die ein Gigabit drüber geht, noch eine Abschirmung drumrum. Das heißt, du kriegst in der Regel da nicht viel raus. Was ich allerdings mal gesehen habe, total clevere Erfindung damals, als die Leitungen noch nicht so schnell waren, war so eine, wie so eine Art Nadel mit Blech hinten dran, die man einfach auf das Kabel draufsteckt und also durch die Abschirmung durch, mitten rein, und die dazu führt, dass also mehr Energie abgestrahlt wird, was man dann im Kommunal-Zoo mit einem Empfänger draußen verwendet.
Das ist aber echter Agentenkram, oder?
Ja, das ist echter Agentenkram, so wie in den schlechten Filmen. Kommt einer rein, macht kurz Pieks in die Leitungen, geht schnell wieder raus.
Dann musst du Druckluftschläuche drumrum machen, dann musst du mal in den Druck gucken, ob der gleich bleibt.
Das haben sie in der Tat auch gemacht.
Die großen Telekom-Leitungen, die unterirdisch verlegt sind, sind alles Druckleitungen.
Genau.
Okay, jetzt neuer interessante Sachen. Wir haben ein Telefonkabel. Das soll nicht abgehört werden. Da wird drumrum eine Leitung gemacht. Du hast die einzelnen Kupferdrähte.
Außen hast du noch einen großen Mantel aus Plastik oder Rohre. Du hast Druckluft drin. Sie messen den Luftdruck. Wenn ihr abfällt, wissen sie, dass irgendwo ein Problem aufgetreten ist, dass das Kabel beschädigt ist. Ein Problem aufgetreten? Was sie noch tun, ist, die Luft ist mit radioaktiven Isotopen versetzt. Sie rennen mit einem Geigerzähler oder ähnlichen Geräten durch die Tunnel und können so relativ schnell das Lack finden.
Das ist ja großartig. Das ist ganz normale Technik, sag ich mal.
Das liegt im Normalen. Ich war mal vor ein paar Jahren in so einem Kabelschacht unten und ich wusste nicht, dass das Druckluft geschirmte Kabel waren und hab da halt mal ein bisschen herum geschnitzt und dann hat es auf einmal irgendwie zisch gemacht und ich hatte glücklicherweise noch irgendwelche Aufkleber in meiner Tasche, die ich dann schnell auf diesen Schlauch gepappt hab und dann irgendwie möglichst schnell wieder aus dem Tunnel geflohen bin.
Also liebe Telekom-Techniker, falls ihr da irgendwie so Punkband-Aufkleber auf euren Leitungen findet, wir wissen auch nicht, wer das war. Thomas, ist deine Frage damit beantwortet?
Jo, ich wollte noch was zu dem Thema vorher sagen, wo jemand gesagt hat, dass er gehört, wie viel Strom hat gerade sein Prozessor verbraucht. Ich hatte es mal so, wenn ich an meinem Soundcard direkt den Kopfhörer anschließe, dann konnte ich hören, wann ich klicke und welche Taste ich auf der Tastatur drücke.
Alles dasselbe. Seitenkanalangriffe, Tempest.
Wir sollten vielleicht mal ein bisschen was dazu erzählen, wie man sich gegen solche Tempeststrahlung schützen kann.
Ich hätte aber hier noch einen Thomas in der Leitung.
Dann gibt doch mal Thomas vor.
Lieber mal den Thomas in der Leitung geben.
Genau, aber das mit dem sagen, wir schützen uns davon, machen wir auf jeden Fall. Ich würde so ganz teasermäßig sagen, machen wir dann in der letzten halben Stunde nach Nachricht.
Super.
Jetzt erstmal Thomas. Hi Thomas.
Thomas. Der hat bestimmt vorhin schon rangehen wollen, dann verzweifelt aufgelegt.
Ah, das ist Thomas und ich, oder? Super, irgendwie bin ich auf den Hut gekommen. Dumme Sache. In der Tat.
Hast jetzt in deinem Telefon geschrien, ohne dass wir geantwortet haben.
Ja, eben. Das mit dem zum Thema schützen ist eigentlich ganz gut, weil dazu habe ich eigentlich auch eine Frage. Und zwar, ich meine, wie schützt ihr euch eigentlich? Also ich meine, ich habe immer so ein bisschen, dass ich führe, je mehr man über solche Technik erfährt, so je paranoider wird man auch ein Stückchen weit. Festzattel vor Schlüsseln tun ja nun sehr viele. Belastet ihr uns auch dabei oder schützt ihr euch auch gegen sowas? Oder wie weit geht das bei euch?
Also wenn du die Wettkämpfe guckst, die haben alles hin, voll Hits auf.
Ja, genau so. Hüte aus Alufolie. Die gegen die böse Röntgestrahlung. Nee, was soll man da sagen? Also es gibt irgendwo eine Grenze, wo wenn du dich mit bestimmten Leuten anlegst, die besser sind als du. So möchte ich das mal ausdrücken. Und das muss man halt einfach einsehen, dass irgendwann hat das einfach keinen Zweck mehr. Und solange man sich mit diesen Leuten nicht anlegt, dann muss man auch nicht paranoid werden.
Also alle, die jetzt zu paranoid sind, sollten jetzt weghören.
Also das heißt, dass man so abgehört werden kann, aber ihr sagt, das Risiko ist so gering, dass das Interesse bei jemanden euch abzuhören so groß ist, so was zu tun, dass ihr sagt, Festplattenverschließung reicht.
Also der Aufwand, das zu tun, ist halt immer noch relativ groß, beziehungsweise halt auch so der personelle Aufwand. Das heißt, du musst halt schon jemand haben, der den Lieferwagen vor deine Tür fährt oder irgendwie die Wand in deine Wohnung oder vor deine Wohnung platziert und es dann auswertet. Und auf der anderen Seite ist der Aufwand, sich halt wirklich hundertprozentig zu schützen, halt irgendwie auch extrem. Also man kann halt irgendwie mal was gegen die Abstrahlung von der WLAN-Karte oder vom Monitor tun, aber jetzt wirklich alles auszuschließen. Also auf allen Wegen sich zu schützen, das ist nahezu unmöglich.
Es kann einem natürlich passieren, dass man aus Versehen in seiner Diplomarbeit das Wort Gentrifizierung verwendet und dann hat man die Jungs jahrelang an der Backe. Es ist ja heutzutage nicht mehr ausgeschlossen, dass sie tatsächlich den Aufwand treiben.
Zu diesem Thema empfehle ich den Podcast der letzten Trackback-Sendung zu finden auf trackback.fritz.de. Da ist ein Interview mit jemanden, der Gentrifikation in seiner Arbeit benutzt hat und deswegen jahrelang abgehört wurde.
Ja, aber da kann man auch nichts machen. Das muss man dann einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen. Ganz großartig, ich hab mal eine Geschichte gelesen von jemanden, der vermutete damals noch zu DDR-Zeiten, er wird von der Stasi überwacht und hat dann also zu Weihnachten am Telefon gesagt, ach und übrigens grüßt sich noch die Mitarbeiter der Staatssicherheit, hat dann nach der Wende seine Akte gelesen, da stand dann fein säuberlich notiert, Herr so und so grüßt die Mitarbeiter der Staatssicherheit.
Okay, aber das kann man jetzt nicht wirklich zum Anlass nehmen und sagen, okay, sie sind wirklich überall. Diese Tempest-Sachen würden wir heute reden. Das ist jetzt nicht das Werkzeug für so 1980-Geschichte.
Das ist noch nicht die Massenüberwachung. Die Massenüberwachung sind Geschichten wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo wirklich jeder überwacht wird, wo die Daten rausfallen, wo drin steht, wo sich welches Handy zu welchem Zeitpunkt aufgehalten hat, wer mit wem telefoniert hat. Das ist die wirkliche Massenbedrohung, wo sich auch jeder verfolgt fühlen muss.
Also man braucht den Aufwand einfach gar nicht zu treiben, um Tempest-Strahlung zu messen und auszuwerten, sondern man hat heutzutage mit Bundestreuern, mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung, mit großem Lauschangriff und viel einfache Möglichkeiten an alle diese Informationen vor allem auch vollautomatisch im Endeffekt ranzukommen. Also auch von einem großen Anteil der Bevölkerung.
Tempest ist sozusagen mehr oder weniger so eine Art sportliche Herausforderung.
Tempest ist halt eher für Leute, die sich wirklich extrem schützen, gerade im industriellen Bereich, wo halt finanzielle Aufwendungen, bzw. das Aufwand, also Wirtschaft, viel Geld oder Geheimnisse oder beides. Also halt irgendwie Sachen, wo man die mal schützen sollte, um Vorteile gegenüber seinen Konkurrenten zu haben und da wirklich großen Aufwand treibt. Und da ist auf der anderen Seite Tempest-Sachen wieder lohnenswert, weil dann auch der Gewinn in dem Fall groß genug ist. Aber halt für die normale Abhöraktion gibt es halt andere Möglichkeiten.
Also ich muss da immer an der Staatsfeind Nummer 1 denken. Weil da war ja zum Schluss auch Gene Hackman in seinem Käfig, den er sich da gebaut hat, um hier ja nicht nach außen abzustrahlen und so was.
Ja, also die Filmemacher haben schon ein bisschen recherchiert, bevor sie angefangen zu drehen. Das stimmt. Sowas kann man tun. Also das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik gibt ja den Grundschutzkatalog heraus und da gibt es diverse Maßnahmen und da gibt es zum Beispiel die Maßnahmen M489 Abstrahlsicherheit, die sich dem Thema Tempest widmet. Und ja, so seine Wohnung mit Aluminiumfolie tapezieren, alles ordentlich erden kann man machen, muss man aufpassen, dass man die Stromleitung nicht vergisst. Also wenn man es wirklich gründlich macht, muss man sich einen Generator und einen Motor hinstellen mit einer elektrisch nicht leitenden Welle dazwischen, damit man auch das entkoppelt oder ähnliche Geschichten. Abstrahlsichere Geräte kaufen.
Also prinzipiell kann man halt erstens versuchen, die Geräte selber zu schützen gegen Abstrahlung. Das heißt, dass die Strahlung nicht aus den Geräten rauskommt. Dann kann man natürlich die Wohnung selber nochmal abstrahlsicher machen. Also wie gesagt, Kupfertapete oder bedampfte Scheiben. Was man natürlich noch machen kann, ist Sulfiridkerne. Was ist das? Tiefpass? Hochpass? Tiefpass. Genau diese Oberwellen, die Andreas vorhin erwähnt hat, die diese Information tragen, halt rauszufiltern. Sulfiridkerne sind einfach nur magnetische Ringe, die um Kabel gelebt werden. Wenn man zum Beispiel an ein Notebook Stromversorgungskabel hat, hat man kurz hinter dem Stecker immer so ein Gnubbel dran. Das ist ein Sulfiridkern, der genau diese hochfrequenten Strahlen rausfiltert.
Aber an den Notebook Netzteilen ist der wegen Tempest dran?
Das ist wegen der elektromagnetischen Verträglichkeit. Also genau der anderen Sache, dass keine anderen Geräte gestört werden. Und was man natürlich noch tun kann, ist explizit Störsender zu unterlegen. Auf den Frequenzen, wo man vermeintlich Strahlung absondert, die nicht draußen gehört werden soll, stellt man daneben einen Sender, der höhere Energie aussendet und damit praktisch die andere Strahlung überlagert.
Das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen. Ob das darf?
Nee, dürfen darf es natürlich nicht, aber machen kannst du es natürlich.
Es kommt auf die Energien, die man aussendet. Natürlich kann man das machen.
Na, wenn du so... Du musst ja Breitband nicht senden. Wir hatten es ja von Rechteckimpulsen und wie alle Leute, die ihre vier Semester Signalverarbeitung gemacht haben, wissen, hat so ein Rechteckimpuls eine unendlich große Bandbreite. Das heißt, der strahlt auf allen Frequenzen gleichzeitig.
Aber auch mit stark öffnender Energie in die oberen Frequenzen.
So schnell nimmt die nicht ab. Also durch die Tatsache, dass du ja einen Tiefpassfilter hast in der Leitung, dass es eine Grenzung gibt. Entschuldigung?
Hallo. Gut, also wir halten fest, es ist schwierig irgendwie mit Ferritkern.
Du musst irgendwie von 0 bis 500 Megahertz senden oder so und da muss man schon viel Energie reinstecken. Das mögen die bestimmt nicht so. Die lieben Kollegen von der RECTP, ist es immer noch die RECTP oder heißen die anders mittlerweile? Die heißen die die Frequenzaufsicht, die Bandwacht.
Also ich habe mal vor Bundesnetzagentur, danke lieber Chet. Vor ungefähr fünf Jahren mal einen Artikel in so einer CB-Funker Zeitschrift gelesen, die haben tatsächlich um Berlin rum so drei Messtürme aufgebaut und überwachen den gesamten Frequenzbereich über Berlin. Das heißt, wenn jemand mit ungewöhnlich starken Funksignalen in Berlin aufpoppt, können sie innerhalb von unter einer Sekunde irgendwie halt ihn triangulieren und orten. Und dann stehen sie halt innerhalb von kürzester Zeit bei dir vor die Tür.
Alles klar. Thomas, weißt du Bescheid? Keine Störsinn installieren. Könnte schnell gehen, dass du Besuch bekommst sonst. Thomas, weil du brav angerufen hast, bist du jetzt auch der, der entscheiden darf, ob wir jetzt noch Musik spielen vor den Nachrichten oder nicht?
Na, ich war der, der vorhin im Chat gesagt hat, ihr seid eine Talksendung und Musik läuft danach im Night Flight noch genug.
Was fragst du auch? Dann kann ich jetzt noch eine Gegenmaßnahme erzählen, die ich besonders lustig fand. Und zwar, wir hatten es ja vorhin von den Tiefpassfiltern. So Tiefpassfilter kann man auch in Software machen. Es gibt also einen Font, den man sich runterladen kann für seinen Computer, der speziell darauf designt wurde, dass möglichst wenig hochfrequente Energie dabei erzeugt wird. Das heißt, man kann sich die richtige Schriftart installieren, dann wird bei dem, der sich das Bild anguckt, das Bild matschig.
Also der Tempest sichere Zeichensatz.
Habt ihr das mal ausprobiert?
Nö, aber das hat Markus Kuhn gemacht, dem glaubt man das normalerweise.
Markus Kuhn ist also ein Name, bei dem man auch googeln kann, wenn man was über Tafeljagd aufhebt.
Der arbeitet am Institut von Russ Anderson in Cambridge. Also der weiß, was er tut.
Das hört sich gut an. Wir machen gleich weiter mit Tempest, vorher gibt es aber Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Jetzt ist die richtige Zeit, ein Instrument zu lernen, eine Band zu gründen und ein paar wirklich gute Songs aufzunehmen. Und wenn ihr das alles schon getan habt, umso besser. Denn er ist wieder da. Eine große Chance für kleine Bands. Legt euch jetzt ein Profil an auf meinfritz.de. Und mit ein bisschen guter Musik seid ihr dabei. Beim großen Finale am 18. September in Berlin. Die besten Bands landen sowieso im Fritz-Programm. Aber die Gewinner erhalten einen Scheck über 10.000 Euro für Musik-Equipment der Marken Kork, Vox und Lag.
Mehr Infos fritzee.
Der Radio-Award für neue Musik. Ihr habt die neue Musik, wir haben den Preis dazu.
Und das hört man um kurz vor halb zwölf.
Fritz-Info.
Nachrichten.
Mit Mario Bartsch.
Ein seit gestern Abend vermisstes Mädchen aus Eilenburg bei Leipzig ist tot aufgefunden worden. Die neunjährige Corinna sei vermutlich einem Gewaltverbrechen zum Opfer gefallenthalten, Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft mit. Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt könnten noch keine Aussagen zu den Todesumständen getroffen werden, da die gerichtsmedizinische Untersuchung noch bevorstehe. Suchkräfte hatten das Mädchen in einem Graben gefunden. Morgen wollen die Ermittler die Öffentlichkeit auf einer Pressekonferenz über den Fall informieren. Die deutsche Krebshilfe warnt davor, ins Solarium zu gehen. Hauptgeschäftsführer Nettighofen sagte der Neuen Osnabrücker Zeitung, er sei durch neue Forschungsergebnisse alarmiert. Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation hatte heute mitgeteilt, dass Sonnenbaden im Solarium genauso krebserregend ist wie Zigaretten und Aspässt. Besonders gefährdet sind Leute unter 30. Im organisierten Drogenhandel werden in Berlin immer öfter Minderjährige als Dealer eingesetzt. Einige Familien würden gezielt unter 14-Jährige losschicken, weil die noch nicht strafmündig sind. Hieß es vom Berliner Drogenhilfeprojekt Fixpunkt. Vor allem in den U-Bahnen der Bezirke Kreuzberg, Neukölln und Wedding werden die jungen Drogendealer eingesetzt. Am Montag hatte die Polizei in Kreuzberg einen 12 Jahre alten Jungen gefasst, der 150 Heroinkügelchen dabei hatte. Rekordweltmeister Michael Schumacher kehrt nach drei Jahren Pause in die Formel 1 zurück. Der 40-Jährige wird für den verunglückten Ferrari-Piloten Filipe Massa an den Start gehen, teilte der italienische Rennstall in Rom mit. Massa war am Sonnabend in der Qualifikation zum großen Preis von Ungarn verunglückt und liegt seitdem im Krankenhaus. Schumacher erklärte auf seiner Internetseite, er könne aus Verbundenheit zum Team diese unglückliche Situation nicht ignorieren und freue sich auf die Herausforderung. Das nächste Rennen findet am 23. August in Valencia statt. Heute Nacht wird es recht mild, es bleibt weiter trocken bei Tiefstemperaturen um 13 Grad. Am Tag gibt es dann weniger Sonne und es kann wieder einzelne Gewitter oder Schauer geben. Das Ganze bei maximal 27 Grad. A9 Berlin Richtung Halle Leipzig. Zwischen Belitz-Hallstetten und Belitz gibt es noch Behinderungen durch Bergerungsarbeiten, die ihre linke Spur ist blockiert. Atzen südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen Jenshagen und Rangsdorf gibt es Gefahr durch einen defekten Lkw, die rechte Spur ist blockiert. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin an 115 Awus, der Zubringe Nutetal statt einwärts. Im Dreieck Funkturm ist die Tangente in Richtung 100 gesperrt, sonst überall gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 89, 85, dann Fritz im Berliner Kabel.
Mit Markus Richter und Andreas im Starbuck von Chaos Computer Club, wo es heute darum geht, Geräte abzuhören und so, dass irgendwie jeder alles lesen kann, nur der kriegt nichts mit, der vor dem Gerät sitzt. Und in dieser Sendung wird auch Musik gespielt. Egal, ob ihr das wollt oder nicht. Reversing Gravity vom Bitmibs Syndicate. Das ist vom Game 3.0 Sampler und das ist, wie ihr euch denken könnt, Musik, die man einfach so und vor allem legal aus dem Netz ziehen kann. Weil so mit Netz geht es hier heute auch um Strom und überhaupt im Chaos Radio. Es geht um Tempest. Mag einer von euch vielleicht zu Anfang noch mal kurz erklären, was Tempest ist? Ich hab mir heute schon den Mund wurstelig geredet.
Äh, das ist, wenn der Computer aus Versehen funkt und deswegen der Nachbar weiß, welchen Porn man klickt.
Und du wolltest jetzt, es gibt zur Sendung auch ein Chat unter irc.freenode.net/chaosradio, also so ähnlich. Und du wolltest doch mal jemand schimpfen, der da im Chat unterwegs ist.
Ja, da wurden Bedenken angemeldet wegen des Rechtecksignals und des kontinuierlichen Spektrums. Und vielleicht formuliere ich es einfach noch mal präziser. Also so ein Rechtecksignal, das ist ja, also wenn man sich das anguckt, diese Flanke da, wenn die durch den Leiter fließt, das elektromagnetische Feld, das da erzeugt wird, ist ja die Ableitung davon. Und irgendwie so die Mathematiker leiten Rechtecke nicht ab. Die Physiker und Elektrotechniker tun das sehr wohl. Da kommt ein Dirak-Impuls raus. Also ist das Spektrum dessen, was bei diesem Rechtecksignal erzeugt wird, die Fourier-Transformation dieses Dirak-Impulses. Und das ist einfach über alle Frequenzen gleichmäßig verteilt.
Wie viele Semestersignalverarbeitungen muss man studiert haben, um das zu verstehen?
Das müsste man eigentlich spätestens nach dem zweiten Begriffen haben. Das ist schon relativ fundamental.
Ich habe zwei Semestersignalverarbeitungen durchlitten, möchte ich an dieser Stelle sagen. Und werde deshalb nicht weiter darauf eingehen, sondern lieber den Normen dran nehmen. Hi. Guten Abend.
Ich habe kein Wort verstanden von dem, was er gerade erzählt hat. Ich habe bestudiert von irgendwelchen Signalen. Ich habe nun einen Funkscanner benutzt.
Und was ist dann passiert?
Dann habe ich die Nachbarn gehört. Aber hier, das hat sich schon zehn Jahre her oder so was, da haben wir das Ding ausprobiert, ein Kaiser. Von Kaiser war das Teil. Und da sind tausend Kanäle und Schnick, Schnuck, Schnack da. Daran rumgestellt. Der hat sich die ja dann alleine gesucht. Und dann hast du irgendwann mal die Nachbarin gehört, komm mir morgen um elf oder ach, was ist das? Belanglose Scheiße halt. Gespandet, leider.
Ist das denn Tempest?
Es ist eigentlich kein Tempest, weil das ist ja sozusagen absichtliche Abstrahlung. Das sind ja Funkgeräte, die absichtlich den Inhalt des Gesprächs funken, so Babyfunken oder Schnurrlostelefone oder so. Also auch Abstrahlung, aber sozusagen beabsichtigte Abstrahlung.
Wir hören nämlich auch gerade deinen Nachbarn oder das Meer im Hintergrund oder was auch immer.
Ich bin auf der Autobahn, ich suche, hier kommt keine Alte Bucht. Ich hab die Rastigkeit an, wenn die ne kommt, aber hier ist leider keine.
Wenn jetzt ein Unfall hättest.
Da wollen wir lieber nicht live dabei sein. Hast du noch mehr mit deinem Funkscanner zu erzählen?
Ist ja eigentlich nicht das, was jeder bespricht. Daher, ich weiß nicht, so richtig passt das nicht.
Alles klar, dann würde ich an dieser Stelle sagen, eine gute Fahrt, Norman, weil wenn es nicht so richtig passt, dann glaube ich, passt das auch nicht so richtig.
Und weil telefonieren im Auto ist ja eh verboten.
Und beim Fahren auch noch und überhaupt.
Tempest und Telefone.
Warte mal, ich würde noch mal darauf zurückkommen wollen, weil ich glaube, es gibt immer noch Leute, die das nicht genau wissen, mit den Funktelefonen. Vielleicht könnte man an dieser Stelle noch mal ganz kurz erläutern, warum das kein Tempest ist, sondern quasi ganz normal, dass man Funktelefone heutzutage auch abhören kann.
Na also, es ist kein Tempest, weil der Sinn dieser Telefone ist, ihre Strahlung in die Gegend zu schicken. Und Tempest eigentlich genau besagt, dass man halt Signale auffängt, die halt nicht dazu gedacht sind, in die Umwelt abgestrahlt zu werden.
Jetzt ist aber schon so, dass ich denke, wenn ich telefoniere, auch wenn es mit einem kabellosen Telefon ist, dass ich nicht möchte, dass irgendjemand anders das hört.
Ja, ja, also das ist natürlich, es ist im Weitesten, es ist halt kein Tempest, aber es ist halt schon die gleiche Kategorie. Also es werden halt auch Funkwellen übertragen und man will halt nicht, dass es abgehört wird. Aber rein technisch ist es halt kein Tempest.
Ist kabelloses Telefon abhören schwieriger oder einfacher als Tempest?
Einfacher, weil die Energie natürlich viel höher ist. Weil die ja wirklich mit viel Energie raus blasen und gerade bei DECK zum Beispiel in den letzten paar Monaten oder zum Kongress letzten Jahres auch gezeigt wurde, dass die Verschlüsselung da nicht wirklich gut ist. Das heißt, man kann sich da eine PCMCA-Karte auf eBay klicken und eine Software installieren und kann halt DECK-Telefone mithören.
Und das für weniger als 1000 Euro.
Die Karten haben angefangen bei 5 Euro und dann kam die Software raus. Der höchste Preis war in dem Bereich von 200 Euro dann. Das ist man auch schon fast bei den 1000 Euro. Aber auf jeden Fall geht das theoretisch viel weniger Geld.
Du hattest jetzt noch eine Frage aus dem Chat, oder?
Genau, die Frage aus dem Chat war Tempest bei Geldautomaten.
Oh ja, das ist ein guter.
Möchte ich auch machen.
Das ist tatsächlich vorgekommen. Die haben relativ simpel gestrickte Tastaturen. Das Problem ist ja immer an die PIN anzukommen. Den Rest des Magnetstreffens kann man einigermaßen raten. Aber die PIN-Nummer nicht. Die Tastaturen an Geldautomaten machen natürlich auch Tempest-Abstrahlung. Es wurde tatsächlich in der Praxis eingesetzt, um an die PINs anzukommen. In Deutschland geht das nicht. Wenn man sich mal diese Eingabepads anguckt, die sind schon relativ durchdesigned. Die sind also aus dickem Stahl, das natürlich auch abschirmt, das auch nicht so einfach aufzumachen ist. Da ist auch mittlerweile ein Verschlüsselungskey drin. In anderen Ländern ist es halt nicht so, da sind die einfacher gestreckt.
Also ich würde sagen, also diese direkte elektromagnetische Abstrahlung geht da vielleicht nicht, aber halt dieses, was wir vorhin hatten, mit per Mikrofon die Tasten abhören, könnte man dadurch auch nochmal probieren.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Also ich muss mit Deutschland aber auf jeden Fall keine Sorgen machen.
Keine Sorgen musst du dir nie nirgendwo machen.
Okay, ich musste in Deutschland nicht übermäßig paranoid sein, was Geldautomaten angeht und Tempest.
Nee, du solltest paranoider sein, dass Vorschaltgeräte davor gebaut werden. Also dass jemand so was an den Magnetstreifen dran packt, wo man seine Karte reinschiebt, wo dann die Kamera dran ist.
Da gibt es eine coole Story. Sie haben, ich weiß nicht genau wo das war, Geldautomaten mit Pfefferspray ausgerüstet und die Pfefferspray gingen halt los, wenn sie halt ungewöhnliches Verhalten detektiert haben. Das hat natürlich die Techniker getroffen, die halt irgendwie an dem Automaten gerade rumgeschraubt haben. Also das muss man sich vorstellen. Sie haben wirklich mit der Kamera detektieren sie, ob da jemand irgendwie jetzt augenscheinlich versucht, was an den Automaten anzubringen. Und dann geht der Pfefferspray irgendwie los.
Automatisch.
Automatisch. Das hat halt wirklich drei Techniker verletzt.
Au.
Aber apropos Geschichten. Es wurden vorhin mehr lustige Geschichten gewünscht. Ich hab noch eine irgendwie, also wirklich finsterste Spooky 007 Geschichte. Vielleicht kriegen wir noch mal den Sound dazu. Die auch mit Tempest zu tun hat. Und ich fang einfach mal zu erzählen. Es gab damals eine Software in den 80ern, die hieß Promise. Die wurde geschrieben von einer amerikanischen Firma namens InSlaw. Die wurde dann in die Pleite getrieben. Die Software wurde aufgekauft von, möglicherweise war es die CIA, alles nicht ganz aufgeklärt. Ein gewisser Herr Maxwell ist durch die Gegend gereist und hat diese Software verkauft. Die diente dazu, Rasterfahndung zu machen. So kann man das am einfachsten erklären. Datenbanken aus verschiedenen Quellen zusammenzuführen, was heute auch getan werden soll mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Damals war das noch neu. Der Herr Maxwell ist rumgelaufen, hat diese Software verkauft an alle möglichen Leute, unter anderem den KGB und diverse andere Dienste. Irgendwann wurde Herr Maxwell vom Boot geschubst. Das ist aber nicht der Bestandteil der Geschichte, der spannend ist. Der spannende Teil ist, dass diese Software eine Hintertür hatte, wo Daten rausgekommen sind. Bekannter war es. Es gibt jetzt einige Spekulationen darüber. Hier schreibt gerade jemand, er glaubt, dass es der Mossad war. Das glauben alle anderen auch. Zumindest war es der Mossad, der vom Boot geschubst hat.
Andere Geschichte.
Andere Geschichte. Reden wir nicht drüber, sondern Tempest. Jetzt war es ja früher so, dass die Rechner nicht unbedingt alle am Internet hingen. Das heißt, wenn man da eine Software drauf gekriegt hat, mit Hintertür drin, also sagen wir mal, man hat an den KGB Promis verkauft und möchte an die Daten, muss man die da irgendwie rauskriegen. Und es ist bekannt, dass die Daten per Funk rausgekommen sind. Und jetzt spekulieren noch alle rum. Es gibt Leute, die meinen, dass da gezielt Rechner verkauft wurden mit einer Wanze drin. Aber die viel plausiblere Erklärung ist, dass da Tempest eingesetzt wurde. Also die Software gezielt bestimmte Zugriffe auf die Busse erzeugt hat, die dazu geführt haben, dass die Rechner abgestrahlt haben, dass über große Entfernung abhörbar war. Also ähnlich wie wir das hatten mit dem Radio und der Musik zu dem Spiel in den 70ern, nur dass dann die Daten rausgefallen sind.
So einen will ich auch zu Hause. Und dann will ich ihm irgendjemand geben, einem Chef zum Beispiel. Wir sind jetzt fast am Ende der Sendung. Ich würde gerne noch ein bisschen mit euch in die Zukunft gucken, weil es hat sich im Verlauf dieser Sendung jetzt so herausgestellt. Okay, Tempest geht. Es ist theoretisch auch ein Problem, was Leute betrifft, die mit wichtigen Dingen zu tun haben. Aber spielt im Alltäglichen jetzt nicht wirklich eine Rolle. Wie wird das in zehn Jahren aussehen? Wird Tempest dann wieder wichtiger, weil alle Leute irgendwie ihr Zeug verschlüsseln? Oder bleibt das eher so eine Art theoretische Überlegung, wo man denkt, naja gut, es funktioniert, aber letztendlich ist es einfacher irgendwie mitzusniffen?
Na, dass das Problem an Tempest ist, dass man halt in der Regel relativ nah ran muss. Also für beliebige Definitionen von nah, aber irgendwie auf jeden Fall muss man sich aus dem Haus bewegen und halt irgendwo hingehen. Und das natürlich immer schon ein gewisser Aufwand. Das heißt, so lange man keine Drohnen hat, die automatisch vor die Fenster fliegen und irgendwie dort die Kamera, das Mikrofon oder was auch immer platzieren, wird Tempest halt immer mit einem gewissen Aufwand verbunden sein. Deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass es sich jetzt für die Sachen durchsetzen wird, sondern da gibt es halt einfach andere Möglichkeiten, die halt einfacher sind.
Aber ist es nicht sozusagen, weil es gerade so ein Ding ist, wo niemand mit rechnet? Ich habe immer dieses Beispiel von der kleinen Rechtsanwaltskanzlei, die einen wichtigen Fall bearbeitet. Da rechnet jetzt niemand damit, dass nebenan jemand sitzt, der sich so eine Technik anstatt schafft.
Also wie gesagt, Kosten und Nutzen. Also ich meine, wenn es halt wirklich ein Lohn des Ziels ist, wird es halt sicherlich auch Leute geben, die Tempest benutzen. Aber das ist halt irgendwie jetzt so, das wird in zehn Jahren so sein. Also ich sehe da nicht, dass es sich großartig da verändern wird.
Würde sich das Problem irgendwann erledigen, weil die elektromagnetische Abstrahlung so klein wird, dass sie dann nicht mehr messbar ist?
Das würde ich sagen auch nicht. Also alles, was man nicht irgendwie im Computer verarbeiten kann, kann man halt auch irgendwie mit anderen Devices wieder messen. Also genauso wie bei Chips, wenn man die halt herstellen kann, kann man sie irgendwie auch reverse-ingenieren. Das heißt, es gibt halt immer eine Technik, um halt die Technik, die benutzt wird, irgendwie abzuhören. Und deswegen, also es wird wahrscheinlich schwieriger werden, mit einem Scwambling oder irgendwie Falschsignale einstreuen, was auch immer, aber unmöglich wird es halt irgendwie nie sein.
Und meinst du, das wird in Zukunft mit den Geräten eingebaut, dass sie quasi gleich das Tempest Anti-Tool mitbringen?
Na, was zum Beispiel die neuen DVI-Monitore machen, die machen halt wirklich Verschlüsselung über das Monitorkabel. Das heißt, du hast halt einen Chip in dem Monitor drin, du hast einen Chip oder den Key in der Grafikkarte und übermittelst die Daten jetzt nur noch gekryptet über die Antenne.
Das heißt, es wird erst innerhalb vom Monitor entschlüsselt. Aber kann man da noch die Abstrahlung von dem Bild messen, oder ist es dann zu sagen, wenn es durchs Kabel ist, ist es gut?
Die bleibt natürlich, ja.
Was es auch gibt, ist ein Ansatz, der bei Chipkarten gemacht wird. Also es gibt ja das Problem, dass Leute Schlüssel aus Chipkarten auslesen wollen, zum Beispiel damit sie umsonst Premiere gucken können. Das heißt ja nicht mehr Premiere. Aber zum Beispiel. Und dass diese Seitenkanalangegriffe, die ja mit Tempest verwandt sind, darauf angewendet werden. Da werden interessante Dinge gemacht. Da wird dann also das Programm so geschrieben, dass es immer gleich schnell abläuft, egal welche Daten verarbeitet werden. Oder es werden intern die Daten so repräsentiert, dass man sozusagen jede Null und jede Eins einmal als Null und einmal als Eins hat. Also sagen wir mal, man hat...
Es hört sich alles gleich an quasi.
Es hört sich alles gleich an. Man hat eine Null im Register, wird bei einem normalen Computer überall der Strom rausgenommen. Und bei dem Computer hat man dann für jedes Bit zwei Zellen, wo immer eine Eins ist und eine Null. Je nachdem welche Eins und Null ist, wird entschieden, ob es insgesamt eine einzelne Null ist. Anstatt dass viel Strom reinfließt und da kein Strom rausfließt.
Ich glaube zu dem Thema sollte man mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Also das ist auf jeden Fall relativ interessant. Nein, über Chipkarten.
Chipkarten, das ist ein guter Plan. Das ist ja Chipkarten-Hacking, weil das ist ein echt spannendes Thema.
Da muss man halt vor allem irgendwie auch mal weiter ausholen, um das dann irgendwie alles ein bisschen näher zu machen.
Okay, das machen wir dann vielleicht in einer der zukünftigen Sendungen. Jetzt ging es irgendwie... Tempest ist eine von den Seitenkanalattacken. Ich hatte dir heute schon erzählt, irgendwie es gibt auch, dass man die Tastatur einfach anhört. Also mit dem Mikrofon. Oder wir hatten auch schon den Chip, den man zum Beispiel...
Ich hab noch eins, das sie nicht hatten. Und zwar Optischabstrahlung. Also das Beispiel ist irgendwie... Licht ist ja natürlich auch eine elektromagnetische Welle. Und das Beispiel, was ich gefunden hab, ist, dass früher, so vor zehn Jahren ungefähr, Switches und Hubs halt diese Blink-LEDs hatten, die angezeigt haben, ob da jetzt Link drauf ist und ob da Daten überflackern. Und was sie halt getan haben, ist halt auf den... Also sie haben halt aus Versehen auf die LEDs halt die Daten rauf moduliert. Das heißt, sie haben halt einfach mit einer Kamera oder mit einem CCD-Sensor halt oben auf die LEDs sich raufgesetzt und konnten daraus die Daten rekonstruieren, die halt gerade über diesen Switch-Sport gelaufen sind.
Oder ein anderes schönes Beispiel, wenn man nachts an Fenstern vorbei läuft, dann schimmert das manchmal so blau, wenn die Leute Fernsehen gucken. Das ist in der Tat so schnell, wenn man da ausreichend schnell hinguckt mit der passenden Elektronik, kann man auch wieder den Bildschirminhalt rekonstruieren.
Okay.
Noch eins? Gehirntempest. Also um mal zu sagen, wirklich in die Zukunft zu schweifen. Also ich mein, im Gehirn sind auch nur elektromagnetische oder sagen wir elektrische Impulse, die da irgendwie rumfliegen. Und die kann man natürlich irgendwie heutzutage auch schon relativ gut von außen, naja relativ gut von außen sichtbar machen. Also hier kriegt man diese Kappe auf.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, man muss schon relativ dicht ran, oder?
Da muss man schon relativ dicht ran. Aber das ist halt auch alles nur eine Frage von Signal und Rauschen dahinter. Das heißt, mit guter Technik kriegt man das wahrscheinlich in später auch von ein bisschen weiter weg. Und ich meine, wenn man halt nicht dicht dran kommt, dann gibt es halt irgendwie auch die Möglichkeit, zum Beispiel in später wird es ja auch mal Implantate geben, die halt direkt mit dem Gehirn interagieren oder halt irgendwie dein Auge als Implantat haben. Und da kann man natürlich dann auch wieder ganz andere Fragen, der Tempest-Sicherheit bzw. der Abstrahlung dieser Geräte irgendwie auf.
Ist das eigentlich heutzutage schon so, es gibt ja irgendwie so schon Herzschrittmacher und irgendwie sowas, dass man da Dinge tun kann oder lesen kann?
Kann man, aber da halt irgendwie, also die haben halt auch so ein über Funk zum Beispiel ein Interface, um das, um den Herzschrittmacher zu steuern bzw. zu programmieren. Also das ist halt wieder die gewollte Schnittstelle.
Die auch nicht besonders sicher ist.
Die auch leider nicht besonders sicher ist, ja. Ne, zu viel Paranoia.
Also wenn du einen Herzschrittmacher trägst, hol dir eine abgeschirmte Jacke.
Vielleicht auch ein Thema für eine andere Sendung. Apropos andere Sendung, wusstest du schon, was ihr nächstes Mal macht?
Ne, das wissen wir erst zwei Tage vorher.
Oh, das ist ja eine Überraschung.
Wollen wir nicht Chipkarten machen? Du kannst dich jetzt freiwillig bereiterklären.
Das ist zwei Wochen nach der HA. Also sollten wir auf jeden Fall demnächst mal machen.
Wir tun jetzt mal Chipkarten auf die Liste, wir tun Medizingeräte auf die Liste. Wenn ihr, liebe Hörer, einen Vorschlag habt, worüber wir reden sollten, worüber wir immer schon mal zwei Stunden lang quasseln sollten, dann schickt uns den. Wir machen das gerne.
Gibt es einen Jingle für die Mail-Andresse?
Ne, ich weiß die auch gar nicht, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Na, chaosradio.ccc.de Ah, ich hätte jetzt gedacht info.chaosradio.de Das geht bestimmt auch.
Aber jetzt hier nicht die Leute verunsichern.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Es gibt doch bestimmt auch ein Wiki und was auch immer. Aber ansonsten irgendwie die Kommunikation.
Also chaosradio.de ist auf jeden Fall die Seite, wo ihr alles findet, was man über diese Sendung zu wissen hat. Zum Beispiel auch den Podcast der Sendung, den gibt's da bald, nehme ich mal an. Und wenn ihr wollt, hören wir uns im... Ne, wir nicht. Aber das Chaosradio hört ihr wieder in einem Monat.
Einen haben wir noch.
Einen haben wir noch?
Genau. Und zwar der 29. Juli. Heute jetzig der 8. Togolstag von Vau Holland, der Gründer des CCC, einer der Mitbegründer und unser quasi philosophischer Vater. Und an den möchten wir hier noch mal erinnern.
Also die letzten fünf Minuten, also eine Minute Schweigeminute und dann noch mal eine Musik.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Problem ist, dass wir hier eine Technik haben, die in den 20 Sekunden nix sagen, geht irgendwie das Notprogramm los. Und ich glaube, das ist eine Welle, die man äh, äh, egal. Ich würde sagen, wir widmen einfach den nächsten Song.
Du meinst ungeeignet für eine Schweigeminute.
Ja, das, um es diplomatisch auszudrücken, so rum. Ich empfehle an dieser Stelle die nachfolgende Sendung. Maxwell, der gerade hier im Chaosradio vom Boot gestoßen wurde, macht jetzt demnächst den Night Flight. Und die folgende Musik widmen wir dann Vau Holland. Ich weiß nicht, darf man das einfach so? Darf man einfach so mal Musik widmen? Professor Click ist es nämlich. Er hat diesen Song extra geschrieben, um an Vau Holland zu denken.
Ciao.
Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.
Und immer schön panierig bleiben.
Danke für's Zuschauen.